it's late at night here in London but
the action has never been more exciting
as magnus carlsen wins the playoff to
become the London chess classic champion
magnus how does it feel to win the
London classic on such a tight I break
it feels very good so I was training the
whole tournament but since it was so
close I always had a chance and today I
was good and lucky enough it seems that
it's more than good and more than lucky
enough you seem to find those critical
moves at the right times and also be
able to handle with the stress and the
pressure of the situation how does your
experience playing in World Championship
matches compared to playing in something
like this well I think it helps it helps
me compared to the other two guys who
were in the playoffs today I had I had
some more experience so essentially I I
was a bit nervous during the Classical
game today against garruk I couldn't
keep my head completely cool but once I
got to the rapids I was very calm and
who would you say was stylistically a
more difficult player for you to face
going into the playoffs had it been mvl
or or Gary I probably gave his a harder
to face because he's so difficult to be
and so so being solid in these kinds of
playoffs is obviously very important now
you mention your game against Grichuk
you know there was this rook takes g4
idea at some point after Knight g4 and
it seems like that gives him very good
chances to win the game is that the
point at which you're referring to when
you said you were nervous no I mean I
didn't actually see that but it was
clear that at some point well I had a
pretty nice position but it got goes out
to control and yeah I was lucky two
together and do you have anybody in
particular that you would like to thank
or that you owe a debt of gratitude to
for for this victory here
very happy with my team especially my
father and Peter they've done done a
great job here and to ya to make sure I
have the best possible conditions to
play good chess and ladies and gentlemen
there is one man who has been behind the
scenes working tirelessly many sleepless
nights in order to make the London leg
of the grand chest or a great success
that's Malcolm pain and Malcolm's here
to present the trophy in a war to Magnus
Carlsen so first I'll be all for the
London chess classic we must
congratulate Magnus for winning the
London chess classic
I'm now of course on behalf of the grand
chest tall congratulations for winning
the inaugural grunt chest tall so as all
of the fans out they are probably aware
e garry kasparov played an integral role
in integrating the london chess classic
norway chess and the sink filled cup in
this inaugural tour and none of that
would have been possible without the
help of michael cretu kofsky michael is
a longtime friend of Gary's helped in in
many of his matches as well and Michael
what is your impression of the over of
the grand chest or for this first year
here I think it was very exciting all
three tournaments and culmination of
this event happened here in London with
the double play offs that problem